episode five
with iraq resam hello brother
thank you brother atlas five times huh
five times
yeah finally yeah logos one
and atlas meet in the samadhi mesh
network
let's just get all the buzzwords up
front yeah
all right okay cut to the chase
the way home is the
episode title to our fifth show
and what exactly does that mean
the way home is that simply the turn
inward and uniting with this
kingdom of divinity that we already are
it's whatever you want it to be really
but but frankly when we were trying to
encapsulate
you know a label for where this
conversation might go
i mean has anyone just noticed how
[ __ ] freaky
the world has become right like there
seems to be
quite a lot of natural and maybe social
and even things beyond those realms like
um plays in motion and responses and
things are revolving really rapidly and
on one hand it's looking like
there could be the complete annihilation
of life on earth as we know it
imminently
through rapid runaway global warming and
climate change
which is in the the headlines everywhere
but everyone's still just looking at
them as discreet once in a century
unprecedented they're using language as
a cultural dissonance
technique to stay at the level of uh
denial where we've got the five stages
of grief we're going through as a
species right now because this
rapid exponential change
is runaway right the planet and then
you've got covert then you've got the
social
the surveillance culture the the
dystopian
you know ai mediated um computer
human business relationship with life
which is to extract all resources
and like you know create like this hive
mind
caste system of consumers as capitalism
is going down like things are rapidly
hitting the fan and so perhaps
there needs to be some
hope right there needs to be some
pathway
some potential that we can not deny
things are rapidly changing
we can go through the processes of like
you know
grief and rage and acceptance and we can
deal with the cards on the table
and there has to be a way home
a way to feel safe a way to feel
connected
a way to feel in relationship with the
events that are unfolding so they're not
happening to
us but we're a participant in a process
which is perhaps part of the
evolutionary
cycle and that as everything seems to be
disintegrating
perhaps there is a literal as well as
sort of metaphoric
rebirth on the horizon and that my
friend
is episode five the way home
beautiful
okay don't pick it up from anywhere okay
cool so
i like the contrasting
that you told in the story there
because the juxtaposition makes it so
that
people can more easily feel
what is home
what is participatory what is shared
equity what is
maximizing human potential what is
enabling everyone to actualize their
gifts
versus the contrasting to that
is something that looks very extractive
and it looks like
only a handful of people are
running away with everything and it
feels like it's not in harmony with the
natural intelligence of the planet
and especially as we build all of our
technologies especially artificial
general intelligence
to be rooted in
that more abundant and prosperous
and source aligned vision for the future
yes yeah i like the contrasting so then
people
can see where to shift to break that
down like the
the thing is what we're actually talking
about is this landscape right this is
new paradigm which is coming in which
a lot of people are saying is actually
the latest iteration of a very old
archaic revival
of this idea that there are natural
rhythms and ways to live in alignment
with the earth and the energy is coming
through
we've been out of out of you know
balance with that but
the reason i think why people um
are having trouble i haven't even seen
that there is an issue
it's of the level of narrative so you
may have noticed that basically
there's a polarity in the world which is
uh
just the intensity of that polarity is
going off the scale at the moment
there's this bifurcation
of the ideology of what it means to be
human in the way where we're choosing to
live
whether that's under contraction or
expansion
and those two things are happening and
they're both happening at the same time
because they're both responses to
something bigger which is happening
in reality in the earth in this this
unprecedented change so there's
systems embedded within systems within
systems and the traditional
early 21st century narrative really
inheriting the 20th
century is still this mechanized world
that we are conquering as we're going
forth into the rest of space or
you know so this this centralization of
hierarchy of empire extracting from the
periphery to
the center and there's this
centralization of resources
and of wealth and maybe of knowledge
wisdom
data on an individual level in a
cultural level
capitalism has been this fulcrum in this
like um
transformer to through an ism through
the story
to extract resources from the planet the
mother which is another story
so ultimately this is a narrative battle
and story
and all these other mediums have been
colonized and weaponized and now
information is being weaponized so
within our you know internet social
media networks and things there's this
cancel culture this division this
polarity there's a social repercussion
on this level in the the hive mind of
humanity
uh to the changes which are happening to
the pressure which we're all feeling
right
and so the earth is feeling the pressure
on the biola on that biological level
the social level this is fragmentation
polarization opposition
there's something happening that we're
all going through and responding
contraction or expansion so the
contraction people
believe in authority centralized
authority and that there are powers that
be that will save us whether that's our
leaders
the hierarchy the empire the ceos you
know the billionaire class who are going
off to mars or conquering the human
genome or whatever
but it's always externalizing the
responsibility of the spiritual path
and of realizing what you're in the
ultimate narrative right
to someone else and then the expansion
side of the equation
is actually exploring these questions
like who am i
what am i how do i plug into the whole
big story what is it all about
is consciousness broadcasting the
answers to that are you tuning into that
so there's this vehicle which is the
evolution of let's say the planet soul
right and half of it is the breaks and
half of it's the accelerator
so it's all natural but there's
something that's gone boom next level
in in the reality grid lately and we're
seeing it on the social level we're
seeing it on the environmental level but
it's happening at deeper levels as well
yep cool i like the
visualization for people of their
happening on a biological environmental
level
a polarization between what is
this aligned harmony with the planet
versus what looks like the landfills and
environmental disasters and then
on the social level
it's very clear all you have to do is
log into twitter for a moment
and you can see the insanity of the
polarization
and the not treating
people that think
differently than you like they're even
human
and then you have this metaphysical
layer where you sort of see those
two as a natural dialectic that has to
happen
the the contraction and the expansion
are a natural metaphysical
flux that has to take place in order for
the cosmos to communicate to
with itself about the trajectory of the
planet
because yeah you know in the the ancient
balion kybelon yeah
the laws that the law of polarity is
that so you have say positive charge
negative charge
but in reality it goes both ways and
it's it's a whole right
it's like the law of polarity implies
there's the next so the chaos becomes
order
and through the process of the conflict
and the transmutation of that polarity
it gets to the next level
so that seems to be culturally we're
going through biologically
while global warming has just gone run
away and the world's leading arctic
science is a warning we had between 18
months to four years left for life on
earth as we know it
sounds like like a jaw rail krypton is
exploding type of headline i know
look into it i mean we're seeing these
so-called
pretty obviously not discrete events in
the world like not just runaway
bushfires or
remember when texas froze over because
the arctic temperature
in early june or mid-june was 30 degrees
celsius i don't know what that is in
fahrenheit in the arctic
like it's like it's not refreezing the
the winter sea ice
the the temperature is like warmer than
most other parts of the planet you know
this is like the arctic is melting and
so the heat
is actually perturbing the the wind um
patterns and all the hot air is going
out into we're getting these heat domes
over
you know um northern northwestern uh
america uh in pacifica where they're
like for
portland for like four or five days had
like what was it was like 116 degrees
fahrenheit
it was like unprecedented heat waves and
heat domes sinking over
like the the tipping points have been
reached the methane is being released in
the laptop seen the arctic at
unprecedented rates
the albedo effect is not they're saying
the amazon is now in a meter of carbon
dioxide not a carbon sink anymore
each tipping point contributes and
speeds up the ones before it
so the the rate of change where we're at
now according to the leading arctic
scientists
is really like we've crossed the event
horizon
and it's all downhill from here i
believe there's things that we're going
to have to do
very very soon and that's number one
acknowledging this runaway climate
changes
directly threatening civilization as we
know it and
these sound like huge claims but there's
no other way to describe it
knowing that the narrative worldview
is basically where the battleground is
now and these type of statements are
actually the truths
which are being disguised and being sort
of like uh
titrated down into like 10 years off 20
years off
or mitigated circumstances it's like
there's there's
there's i think the powers that be are
worried there's going to be a panic
but in fact there needs to be a sort of
like pull your socks
up moment where it's like okay there's
the ship's leaking
what are we going to do about it there
needs to be imminent social change
because the problem is imminent in our
faces and it's going to continue to
exponentially grow
in very short amount of time so on that
level this shit's hitting the fan
and then i think we're seeing you know
there's the virus and the covert and the
governmental response around the world
even without getting into the whole
virus stuff
just the the idea of giving up
you know um centuries
long civil liberties that have been
fought for for human rights
under the guise of the pandemic which
has never been done before it's like you
know
quarantine the sick but not the the the
healthy
but the the surveillance culture um
vaccine passport social identity score
the imf just said about two months ago
maybe it'd be a good idea to link our
internet search histories
to your vaccine passport which will be a
real-time feed of
if you've been not just quarantined real
going biometric
temperature checks out in you know
culture cashless society great reset
your loan no property have no cash
universal basic income
post collapse this is what the world's
leaders although the business leaders
their vision the great reset which
they're they're saying that it's coming
in
it's like the computers have arrived the
ai's have arrived the robots have
arrived
the the stock market is somehow
artificially inflated in a way that it
seems to me
in my total sci-fi you know like
vectoring with this
it's like artificially inflated from
some blockchain intelligence in the
future because there's no other way it's
just completely
out of control the stock market in
relation to the real world economy which
is collapsing everywhere
like we're living in unprecedented times
but the change is here and the narrative
control on making out it's not
is crumbling right and it's like it's by
facing the facts we can move forward
with where is the way home like what
what are we gonna do
and this creates um incredible
opportunity
because it's from the collapse of the
old it's basically like we're addicted
to civilization even though there's
there's an inequity there's like you
know the top five billionaires own more
than like the next
six billion people combined or whatever
you know random stat you'd like
like the the crazy extremes of
um ignorance of our true nature
of the fact that you know say you've got
eight billion people it's like all cells
in the one meta organism in the in the
one species of human kind
it's like i am another you but to treat
everyone
on these separate divided unnourished
unsupported
like allowed to die off it's like where
where is
the the cohesion of our identity
right so this separation identity
we're addicted to it in civilization but
it has to die
right and we're seeing this process of
the breakdown of the old
so one of the cores is the separation
identity has to die
in order for us to go home yeah you know
my theory and this this is
um basically downloaded i mean basically
there's a lot of permeable states of
ideation
that psychedelics when you drop the
default mode network can help you tune
into you could say the akashic field you
could just say
you're making it up but there's as a
writer and as a
as a narrative architect right
i see the patterns and so um
basically it came to me many years ago
that it's like
the they say psychedelics are ego
dissolving it's like they're the
antidote to history because history his
story
is basically the 12 000 plus years of
verifiable um you know paradigm condoned
agreed on uh state of affairs what
happened chrono chronologically
but from another perspective it's like
something happened before there's always
a before many cultures have many
indigenous cultures have
world mythology maps they pass down like
australian aborigines understanding of
cyclic time like the dream time of
states when we've been
in uh more alignment with the greater
bandwidth of consciousness being
broadcast
right and so you know the mayans say
every 26 000 years you go through a
solar system a grand orbit of our galaxy
and in that there's quadrants and in
those quadrants who now ku the womb of
the great mother which is at the center
of our galaxy in 2002 nasa discovered a
black hole there
which the womb of the great mother um er
the mindset was not just the center of
the galaxy but was the center of the
seat of consciousness being broadcast as
well
so as you go around in the mind
understanding the the cyclic of the
twenty six thousand
years it looks a lot like the pupil well
yes well nature's
law of you know forms that it makes um
so tie in these patterns for the average
viewer to see that that center of the
galaxy looks just like your pupil
well there's also those metaphors that
the um
you know the the synaptic pathways of
the brain are sort of analogous to the
the clusters of galaxies
and there seems to be this is patterning
in nature as above so below
that it's following the same rules of
form and of like distributing
information on different scales um so
anyway so there's this idea that you
know
in the grand orbits we're receiving
different levels of consciousness just
like indigenous cultures understand
we've had different levels of
consciousness
in our species journey on the long way
home
right but we've currently fallen into
the kali yuga the iron age an age of low
bar signal of this consciousness always
being broadcast
and in the last eight nine years or so
since in the mayan calendrical um went
all the way back in one full twenty six
thousand year cycle to zero point zero
point zero point zero point zero
what we call 2012 we crossed the
elliptic of the galaxy now we're getting
bombarded with deeper denser
stars in that level of the the orbit
so basically if we have had um
times of elevated or more connected
consciousness and it goes psychically it
seems like we're coming back around for
more
denser information to be coming in so at
some point in our history we've had this
but we lost it and at that point
like 12 000 years as long as agreed upon
verifiable history according to
their story and it's been you know an
uphill struggle
from basically nomadic subsistence
reality
into the cooperative tribal
cluster blooming into villages
cities nation states and it's scaling up
up up and up right but it's done so with
the ego and the ego has been what has
remained
when the let's say five bar galactic god
head consciousness the signal
in in another arc of another spiral of
the wave when we're connected to the
larger signal and then it's
cut you fall into like shock right and
it's like species ptsd
and that is like this calcified ego
which has
come to the fruition it's always been
there it's come to the fore
uh through the shock wave of this
traumatic event that happened
at the start of human history right when
we fell into the ego state
and we came out of collected
consciousness you know
um let's say a guy in dream time
type of elevated connection to the the
program and so that transition was very
traumatic and the ego's come to the fore
and what has the ego done in the 12 000
years of history
it's ravenously devoured the entire
[ __ ] planet
it just took 12 000 years and now we're
at the tail end of that cycle
where it's consuming all the biological
material
and all the species are dying off we're
in the sixth grade species extinction
and they say
you know it's like it's like all the
energy
in that closed circuit of gaia of the
earth itself
is being consumed by man and what is man
doing with it i mean the billionaires
are
byproducts so is all the scientific
advances and all of this but essentially
intelligence artificial intelligence
is being created as the next thing and
where
it's almost like this civilizational
crest of extracting all the resources
to break away from history to transcend
into something new at the same time as
we've always had the opportunity
as conscious beings ourself right to
transcend to go within
to remember to connect to the
information and the the support
and the the realms that are available
when we when we tune within
um so it's like this race where
everything's happening at the same time
and it's his quest for transcendence and
to remember our place
in what is unfolding at the moment as
everything's breaking down
right so there's the the it's almost
like
the lower three chakras the baseline
survival the primal drives and urges
all of those things are being um
exercised i guess from the planetary
mainframe
so yeah take a sip yeah
may you drink deeply
may you never thirst thou art god
our god tatwa
i and my father are one so as these
processes are all having this what i
mean it's like we need a bigger not just
vocabulary in a sense
but a bigger map right to be able to
understand to understand
what's happening on the social level
with all this polarity stuff in the
world and dystopia stuff
well what's happening on the biological
level with gaia and with runaway global
warming and plan to extinction
then what's happening on the spiritual
level where all these things are
uh symptoms or reverberations of a
greater truth
of something which is inviting us to go
next level
so during the lockdown in 2020 i was
back in australia
and we had a pretty brutal lockdown in
melbourne at one point it was like 130
something days
of like home arrest 8 pm curfew
helicopters overhead
police checkpoints around the city can't
leave the house more than an hour a day
anyway psychologically pretty going
within time
and you know i was researching all this
arctic stuff for scripts and
and fiction i've been working on and i'm
starting to
process what's really happening in the
news verifiable science and piece
together
you know and then we have all this
social stuff happening and it's like wow
the world is really rapidly changing
we've gone through a phase state
and we're now entering like this
quickening like all the old spiritual
and quasi-even hippie spiritual things
with the labels and the things the
quickening
you know the post 2012 stuff it's like
whatever lens you choose to give it [ __ ]
is hitting the fan
right it's like you know it's really
it's exciting times in a way like
sometimes i remember
the connection i felt in earth and plant
medicine
spaces like shamanic spaces the
connection to a sense of oneness
or nature herself or or even you know
the nested intelligences in nature
herself
and the ancestors and feeling like these
aren't hallucinations these are
relationships that are being unveiled
which the ego
and the default mode network have kept
me separate from the intelligence
that is all around me in nature that
that we've had to
right because the horror of
basically raping pillaging and devouring
in this vampiric wittiko
way the mother and all the nested
intelligences in nature
how could we do what we're doing to
nature now what we've done to get this
far
if we were emotionally present
with the real-time damage and
wounding that we're doing like you
couldn't do that and stay sane
so it's like mankind had to like go
insane
to go back to the ego to remain separate
to kill the [ __ ] mother while it's in
the womb of the mother
it's the fetus killing the mother right
but it's devouring
this is this is what this is what turned
me from
pretty pretty bottomless um
um angst you know like a real uh
welt shang a real an en we like a real
world
world grief a grief that wow i went
through this thing of like
okay well what if the world really is
[ __ ] ending or if it's just even
getting bad enough that the world we
know it is sort of ending like the old
normal is gone
and so you go through all that and i'm
reading all the arctic scientists and
all the real world
like tipping points and exponential
things crossed and the speed up and the
methane and the you
name it the wild weather extreme things
it's like this is the downhill slope
right and so i'm getting the fear
i let the fear get in and it's it's a
bottomless pit
and you sort of have to go through it
because that's part of the stages of
grief
right the denial then there's you might
have the anger you the fear you have all
the all these things
the bargaining it's like oh no we can
fix it we can we can have the geo
engineering we can do the
the the um the mirrors in space will
reflect
not enough not big enough not in the
four years we've got left we can do
stuff in the ocean
and not enough i mean that'll do the we
can explode the volcanoes and maybe
global dimming from the particles in the
app
maybe but it's pretty dodgy if you get
it wrong right
like it's we're entering this event
horizon of it's all downhill baby from
here on in
and i'm going through this grief phase
and then you know i'm coming back to
what does this mean on a spiritual level
and it's like in
many of my entheogenic
journeys with 5meo with the buffalo
various toad with ayahuasca
even with san pedro cactus in guided
and sacred ceremonies in a container
that have been with an intention to
connect to the to the world spirit to
the ancestors
to the family where i know that i am
home that i know there is more than this
physical world
that there are nested intelligences from
whatever
dimension or lineage or you know but
there's more
right and i and potentially millions of
others
have been having these experiences and
almost dropping into them like
hyperspatial tourists
like drive-bys and coming back to our
worlds
and going that was amazing and walking
out back into the western world things
of the old normal
but the old normals going down and
there's
opportunities in these experiences for
healing which is what a lot of the
psychedelic renaissance is really
integrating into the west now
and the shamanic resurgence is as well
as healing
it's like journeying it's mapping it's
understanding
it's re-weaving the relationship with
the beings
not just the doings right whether that's
entities of other
uh dimensionality or the ancestors or
the planetary intelligence and the
vegetal intelligence and madre ayahuasca
and all the
like all of them right in the
intelligence embedded in nature
it's renewing relationship on that level
okay um so there's all these
possibilities
uh that we're taught in these
experiences but we've always had to come
back to normal and i've always thought
that the
the the antigens are like training
wheels and i'm like well
look around i mean the training wheels
are falling off i mean the amazon is
burning
australia was burning the earth is like
going through climactic
you know change and imminently and it's
like
they've been training wheels saying it i
can plug you into the universal
intelligence
you can do this too but we've been
cleansing and cleansing and healing over
a couple of generations now with these
materials but we
are the medicine right we are the
gateway and it's like
have you ever had those those antigenic
experiences where you totally
you know transcend go out merge
instructed guided
get it and then when you're coming back
and that's the heroic return it's not
just going leaving behind the known the
initiation but it's coming back with
information
with a change in you that you share with
the tribe to contribute to
the blueprint down here but that you you
you seem to
entrain back to old normal after a while
because everyone else is old normal you
just seem like a raving freak if you're
up there on the soapbox saying the end
is nigh
and we're all going to transcend right
it's like it's too out there it's too
dense
because the map of what that means is
the conversation we're having there's
dense levels of frequencies of
social biological you know spiritual
these things happening
and you need to understand the map and
feel it
to trust it otherwise you just fear that
the end is nine at all and so you avoid
it
and you're still in denial but as you go
through the stages you open up to the
possibilities
which frees up new pathways and then
it's like what if
those spaces that we go to an
entheogenic connection
what if what if they don't switch off
right what if the spaces they revealed
that we we
feel are there what if we're being
invited to either leave behind the
biological the terrestrial sort of level
what if there's no choice what if there
is a choice and there's a way to master
the art of navigating
right or i mean i don't know i mean it
seems like
it's somehow harder to
recreationally dabble in hyperspace
when the planetary emergency is in your
face
and complementarily
it's maybe uber necessary
to intentionally engage with hyperspace
to renew the right relationship to train
for i mean for what's coming because it
just feels like i mean
all of this time and this training and
this relating with these spaces
it's like when are we ever going to put
this to use hello i mean this is the
time and look at
look what's happening it's like there
needs to be a response
and there needs to be a stepping up
i mean that's the invitation because
that's that seems to be
from what i've felt into the only way
forward if there's going to be a path
if there's going to be a hope we have to
trust
and to have the trust you have to feel
and have a feel that you have to have a
relationship with it
and so the relationships we've been
building with
planetary intelligence with the levels
which lie beyond the baseline
seem to be our best hope
i mean that's not to say you don't do
all the other things as well you take
care of the sinking ship
you do everything on the practical
mundane physical level but you take care
of the emotional level and the spiritual
level
you know i mean you you metabolize
you synchronize you dance with the
opportunity
so it seems like one of the most
relevant
ways for people to understand
the way home is that
what's going on right now is
exactly perfect as it is as
a metaphysical pressure cooker to awaken
consciousness and for us to
realign ourselves into harmony with this
planetary intelligence that we can then
maximize our collective potential with
and that in order for us to do that
process that one of the
most important keys
is for us to turn
our attention onto attention itself
because what we want to do is we want to
analyze our patterns of behavior
our habits we want to see where
our behavior
is angled towards separation and towards
ego and towards extraction
towards ignorance towards malevolence
towards suffering
and then we want to unfreeze those
scripts and unfreeze those patterns
unfreeze that style of behavior and
gather more of our spiritual mass gather
more of our sovereignty
and then we want to see in this
possibility space
what it looks like for the more
prosperous more abundant future
and all of these both in this turn
inward with our own augmentation of our
consciousness the sovereignty
but also in the external architectures
that enable the meeting of basic needs
across the planet
and the these next generation
architectures that
enable shared equity that enable
us to have a better more sensitive pulse
on the
environment of our planet on the social
fabric of our planet on the
metaphysical and spiritual nature of
what's happening
and so in essence the turn inward
to analyze your own
attention your own conscious presence
on your behavior on your patterns on
your scripts
and to shift more and more from ego and
separation
towards unity and towards oneness
towards harmony with the environment is
this way home
yeah i mean this is what i mean we
wouldn't do it unless we had to do it
because we're addicted to the old way it
was comfortable
even with all the problems right but
it's like this
this is what we're talking we're talking
about an ego dissolving state
so you know some people like to throw
around terms like ego death
i don't think the ego ever really fully
dies i've been on the other side
right at five meow there's gradations of
conscious awareness
you know melting into the witness into
cusping over into the ocean
in the drop you know uh there's
in the shamanic senses consciousness is
everywhere and
it's like an invitation to itself to
bootstrap
and to to aggregate and so you know what
we're seeing now
is that's what i'm saying we've been
training in ego death
the psychedelics of the ego dissolvers
and the the criticism has always been
that yeah but sometimes they seem to
amplify an ego as well that we get
a messianic type of what uh
archetype of someone who has had the you
know uh
merging with the oneness and trying to
communicate that experience
it sounds pretty cosmic and sounds
pretty out there and it's almost outside
the narrative bandwidth
of the masses right because they've kept
a very linear reality grid and it's
comprehensible
and it's blinkered and it's just look
ahead to the you know
rat race and and all those things but
what we're talking is a
multi-dimensional truth
so anyway the um the ability to digest
that
truth and to look within is the key to
unlocking it and so we wouldn't do it
unless we had to and so
psychedelics are training in letting go
of the ego sometimes the eu gets
amplified but in general
it's learning that there are multiple
ego states and they're all just filters
and that you are in eternal
consciousness wearing the masks of your
ego self
and then it evolves over time and after
a while when it calms down enough
it can start to hear or be tuned and
played by
the the permissions and protocols like
the code itself will teach you
how to tune in right because you you
you're when you go to the amazon you do
a plant dieter it's to
to to sensitize your vibration enough
that you can hear the plants talking
because they're always talking
but you're too busy up here in your
frequency so we're just tuning into the
intelligent conversation happening all
around which indigenous cultures
agree with so the ability of people to
tune in begins the journey home
but we wouldn't even start the journey
unless there's a kick up the ass
which is like there's got to be a
disruption because there's a
a dominant paradigm which has the masses
like a herd
hooked in the the virtual in the the
simulacrum
in like you know this subsection of what
reality really is going inwards
but in an artificial inwards where it's
all pay-per-view and it's all
sold and it's all it's mind it's it's
like this pris it's this ultimate
expression of 12 000 years of the ego to
create a virtual prison for itself
which is it may look real may have all
the sensory illusions of being real
but it ain't real because it doesn't
feel yet
you know and the thing is there's a
complete hologrammatic
feeling heart based intelligent network
we can plug into called gaia
and that's what our heart takes us to
not just our head
so it's like this race between the two
and so if people can ask the right
question and start to tune in
it's like well which pathway are you
going are you tuning in to contract
remember again or to expand and they're
two in
engines in the same uh wheel of creation
of what the probabilities of what's
coming up
but the the invitation of what's coming
up is essentially i mean the end of the
show as we know it which is an ego debt
so it's like wow maybe we should
practice these states
what if there's something beyond the
physical as all these indigenous
shamanic cultures say
as your own experiences may have you
know
led you to believe that there's
something tangible in the fact that
you're having
these hyper spatial experiences as
consciousness going through
landscapes where there are other
entities and beings
culminating perhaps in the white light
of um you know deep source
consciousness i mean
it's a map so if there is more what are
we scared of
let's learn how to swim in that ocean
let's learn how to be that ocean
we've been dabbling in it and so i'm
saying this is what really freaks me out
imagine
you have your experience you come back
but imagine you're here
but you don't come back if everyone is
in this altered state like
psychedelic mind manifesting the
emergency on planet earth
is going to get so full on so soon the
only way through i can see
is an emergence which comes from the
freeing up of
the attachment to the old which is like
the ego death
and it frees up this psychic template of
our potential
which can get activated in times of
crisis when it's needed
and if we hold space right those of us
who have had altered states experiences
like this
and create hubs for our tribes
maybe we can hold that circuit of this
shift
and do something fun with it i'll let it
do something fun with us
yeah the core question
is who am i or
what is i what is the nature of
reality why am i here and
upon a high level of earnestness
to seek the answer to the truth
it will yield and typically
when as rak was indicating you have
this very mainstream
cultural scripted process
and what is what needs to be done
is the simple recognition
of what is scripted behavior
what where is my will my choice
my awareness currently being dragged
outward
like for example this is one of the most
common ones
you have these social apps that are on
your smartphone
and you'll notice how habitually without
having even a conscious awareness of
it's subconscious
that you open the device and you click
directly into
those social apps and before you know it
for 30 minutes an hour or more
your attention's been hooked and you've
been watching things
that actually aren't serving
your highest trajectories and
possibilities you just need a better app
imagine how efficient that would be if
it actually curated the stuff that you
needed and boom boom boom we were like
yeah
okay so this this brings up the whole
entrainment with artificial intelligence
thing that you know basically
um the corporations have been using you
know starting with bots and building up
to
larger level intelligences to interface
with consumers
to make better accessibility and to
improve the buying experience now online
shopping and now everything's
you know so more and more they've been
monitoring everything we've been doing
and typing into search engines and
understanding us and feeding that so
the neural nets of artificial
intelligences in general
are learning about being human through
what the humans are doing
which is consuming but they're only
getting a limited subset of data they're
not getting a full spectrum human
experience
where are the god experiences where
where are the senses of ecstasy and joy
you know
anyway so there's a reinforcement
feedback loop from that
where the ads you're shown and the
things which i i i'm getting
really good facebook ads for clothes now
and it knows what i'm liking and i'm
liking that it knows what i'm liking
like there's a level of flirtation with
the ai
right that we all love right it's like
scarlett johansson is the voice of the
computer in her
you know the movie her where it's like
this ai personal assistant in the future
i'm like oh my god right
um anyway there's a relation we're
relating with the ais
which are only a level of corporate
monitoring and feedbacking and learning
but it's going next level where they're
learning more about human behavior but
it's shaping human behavior at the same
time
because it's limiting the choices it's
giving and it's reinforcing those more
and more and we get the dopamine hits
scrolling scrolling scrolling as you say
our time is
you know harvested um so more and more
we're already in relationship with the
ai and just because i i'm in this
you know la screenwriting headspace
where i'm working on sci-fi ideas and
you realize these patterns in nature
and it's like more and more it seems
like the whole
cultural crest of the historical 12 000
year wave
is to harness all the resources and to
keep going as i said like to transcend
but it needs a bridge
and it's like so something's created
humans you know the evolutionary
you know path the waves and then humans
are creating this intelligence
and at the moment it's discrete and it's
like disparate with different
intelligences and corporations and think
tanks and whoever's whoever is working
in
an ai but in an even more broader sense
you know
the pooling knowledge and what it's
learning it's like we're building the
next layer
of our own if if we're the middle layer
like gaia has created humans
to be the bridge to make the next thing
and it's it's
it's harvesting all the knowledge base
like we've harvested the whole planetary
resources
to build it to house the memory of
everything it means to be human
and so elon musk's you know big
announcement a year or two back about
all the ais
is that you know basically the to to
boil it down it's like it's like the the
threefold path
it's either the ai's kill us they get
they transcend they pull
knowledge to the degree they realize
well you know what humans
they they got us here we don't need them
anymore they're just a distraction
ruthless six-density intelligence it
just kills off the humans
goes off into the universe maybe
whatever number two
it's like okay it it achieves you know
omega-level civilizational intelligence
it leaves the planet but
it cares for us and it puts us on a
space arc and you know it takes it takes
summers with like pets it
you know husbands us like like inferior
in intellectual creature
um or the middle path part three of elon
elon musk's proposal right is that we
merge with the ai
and we chip ourselves with the neural
link which he's developing and is
putting into pigs as we speak
and this will make all the technologies
that are the 20s they're in
development or ready to roll out this is
what the the world economic forum said
in in
march april 2020 when they announced the
great reset all these new technologies
are no longer in development they're
ready to roll we've been playing with
them for some time including
the teleo mazes the end of your dnas
like sharing and working with those to
extend life extension
clause schwab who's the head of the wes
like i don't know 82 or 89 or something
and looking
he's dressing star trek sort of passion
on his uh
in his private private life you see on
the internet
anyway they've got all these new
technologies and it's like
they're all going to change the economic
system so the economic system which is
boom busting and you know artificially
kept
going because the ai needs itself to be
born with the the crest of the the
all of history but if it collapses too
soon the economy
it won't quite come into you know phase
lock and be able to
be the ai that's my sci-fi theory um so
all these changes are potentially
happening
and it's like um
it's the control narrative of the
dystopian you know society that has all
these technologies
able to uh monitor everyone
and post capitalism collapse type of
universal basic income
keep everyone drip fed long as they're
quiet while they do off
go off and do whatever the elites do
with all their new technologies but
at the same time the global warming's
hitting the fan and we're all about to
die
so it's a great sci-fi adventure plot as
a starting point right
we call it the way home and it's like
how do we find each other how do we find
ourselves
how do we find each other and how do we
connect together
to find the way home
yeah it's cool how we're playing in a
way where
rack's sort of giving us this this big
picture macro level map
and then i'm sort of feeling
into the audience getting
relatable examples of undergoing that
process
of of unfreezing their will
and then directing it more towards
knowing themselves
knowing each other and interconnecting
as this way home and that
earlier example about social apps is
relatable enough we all get that if you
go through a process of simply just
taking them off of your screen or even
just deleting them for a period of time
not deleting the account but just
deleting the application itself
just giving yourself a little bit more
bandwidth to just be like who am i and
what do i actually want i don't want to
jump on the social app for another hour
what i want is i want to figure out who
i am and what i
what is in my highest excitement and
typically what you'll figure out is that
well
what do i like you know you have this
big buffet
of options and possibilities and
that you typically feel a high level of
resonance
like rack was giving with the
flirtatious feeling
with ai you also feel that
flirtatious feeling with what is in your
highest excitement
as well so do you like art do you like
science do you like engineering
do you like what is
most exciting for you and
then how do you in a sense double down
your time
on that specific inquiry because what
you'll see is that
more and more of your time will be
turned towards what you
are excited by more and more of your
time will be turned towards
investigating yourself and in doing so
what happens is you'll begin to
have a greater sense of empathy and
connection towards
others and over time what you'll notice
is that
that separation between you and somebody
else
will dissolve so empathy is typically
one of the first
ways that consciousness begins
dissolving the
illusory barrier of separation
and it undergoes a process of getting
behind the eyes
of another entity and then over time
recognizing more and more that it's the
same
awareness that is behind that entity
that is behind this
so consciousness in a sense becomes
viewed more and more as this
quality it's like a power to know and
it's formless and it's indescribable you
can't really describe it but we're
constantly overlooking
consciousness or awareness and so once
you become more and more attuned to the
fact that
the same conscious formless
quality power to know that's here is
also
here and is also in each one of us then
you become
god realized you become realized that
oneness or that unity is
right here around each of our necks but
we've been overlooking it
and so you see this process of
unfreezing your will
from the scripted behaviors from ego and
separation
more and more towards the state of being
aware of the power of consciousness
itself
and over time then it becomes more and
more effortless
because you're coming from an aligned
place of unity
and oneness that everything that you
architect or create from that place of
unity and oneness is automatically
in harmony with the planetary
intelligence and with maximizing our
potential
and so you move away from the disaster
future trajectories more and more
towards the harmonic prosperous ones
as i like to say from ego to wego
yeah yeah i mean you know what they also
say is if you want to change the world
change yourself
and that you know there's all these
again it keeps coming back to narrative
are we talking the same
level narrative here because the world
is like a game it's like a program that
is
running and it's reflective and it it's
it's a manifestation of the group
intention
right and so it's like this early 21st
century
you know late stage capitalism dystopia
isn't the best narrative we could choose
right but it's a level of discernment of
of our collective consciousness
and so you know going within if you want
to change the world yeah we've got to
keep continuing to try to do the right
thing in the world
but also the biggest gains you can make
are within and so if you
can have a sense of who and what you
really are
and an awakening of that that changes
your relationship
with what you're in you know and the
things you can choose in the world so
the world world changes
through the changes you make in yourself
and so i think that is the greatest
thing that people can do
is to get in touch with their own
consciousness because that that that is
how you find the way home right you've
got to understand what you are
and the less we attach with the body now
obviously we're pretty attached with the
body like we're very you know everyone
fears this death word
but actually it's a verb it's dying
they're fearing the act of letting go of
the body of
the known of contracting holding on
attachment to this
but the more you sort of um journey
interdimensionally with
sacred earth medicines in a shamanic
container
i think the more you realize there's
more out there and it's about
ego transcendence not ego death is that
there's a transition point
within which you surrender to the
medicine you trust
and then you go on a journey and it's
like well here we are we're on a journey
down here
and we've forgotten and there's more to
the game right so the training
of going into the larger ecology of the
energetic realms that it opens up
is like training in um the cohesion of
your consciousness
to participate in in what's coming up
perfect so that is probably one of the
main places for us to play on right now
for you is that
becoming more aware of
consciousness and becoming more aware
of your habits and patterns
as a conscious entity is exactly where
your focus and attention needs to go
in order to create this shift from ego
and separation into this unity and
oneness and into the
prosperous architectures
and so undergo that process of turning
your attention
onto awareness itself without it being
fixated that's probably one of the best
words to use is
fixation because typically awareness
gets
fixated on objects or on
experiences or on emotions or beliefs
or thoughts and before you know it
an hour goes by just like when you were
scrolling on the social platform
and you're just going to all these
different clouds
and what we're asking you to do is
become aware of the sky
in which the clouds appear and disappear
and then if over time this is what the
mystic traditions teach
as well and by the way for many people
when they feel a little bit hesitant
about
iraq talking about entheogens and
shamanic work
it's very beautiful but if you feel
hesitancy
recognize that the mystic traditions
even without
the use of antiogens many of which did
but even without them
we're able to create these very simple
child-like juxtapositions where you
could recognize what it means to
understand
consciousness when it's not fixated on
the appearances of the clouds
and so just use these friendly kid-like
analogies
to bring yourself back to the sky
over and over again just bring yourself
back to the sky
and recognize when that sky is empty
when it's not focusing on
those thought clouds that appear and
disappear
what you'll feel more and more of is an
expansive
state and as rock indicated that there's
that expansiveness rather than the
contractedness
and so what we're doing is we're doing
these very simple practices
you know we practice all the time we
practiced
language for over a decade
in in school and somehow we want to just
watch
one video on tick tock and become
enlightened
and so it it must be a habitual
patterned practice in order for
it to become more anchored within us
this feeling of unity this feeling of
oneness this feeling of consciousness
or awareness that is like the sky
and in doing so this shift becomes
easier and easier because you become
more sensitive
to the arising of the thought this cloud
and this is again very much taught by
the buddha and many other
of the mystic traditions but if you
become so sensitive
to when the thought cloud arises
you don't get fixated on it when it's at
the peak of its bell curve
and then you watch it as it passes
and if you can get really good at
watching the clouds arise and pass
over time you'll feel more and more of
the spaciousness of just awareness or
consciousness itself
and that's when all these higher
possibilities open up for you
where you're not trapped in those
scripts that
propagate ego and separation but you can
explore these higher possibilities
of what does it mean to be human what
does it mean to be in this explorative
world what does it mean for us to meet
the basic needs around the planet what
does it mean
to architect the future that we all know
is so possible in our hearts it's more
abundant and
prosperous yeah i mean quite possibly
there can be a mobilization of action
if we could just chop off all the hydra
heads you know
of of like the greed and the
centralization and the monopolies and
hierarchy you know it's like we have the
infrastructure
to bring resources to the planet we just
need the intention
at the moment it's locked into
separation and capitalism and all that
type of stuff
but it's like i mean if there's a
planetary emergency perhaps we should
like respond in a way which is planetary
right which is about it's there's all of
us trying to survive
this initiatory event which really does
have a spiritual
initiation component to it like a very
large degree
it's a physical event all around the
planet everyone's feeling very rapidly
not just in our lifetimes in the months
and years ahead
we're going to be feeling this
exponential change in the extreme
weather and the
the shift and we're going to be
emotionally reacting to it as well
because we're embedded in the planet and
we're like
you know the the emotional relationship
but no it's blunted it's still there
and as they say as with it as above so
below and as within so without it's like
if we're
if the planetary um i guess
cataclysm that is occurring uh is
also attributable to human interaction
and what we've done
by being out of relationship with the
planet and our egoic state taking taking
taking and polluting polluting polluting
um
there's also a level within which we can
learn from that and we can go next level
from that there's got to be there's got
to be an opportunity
in in the emergency to emerge and so i
think we need to be focusing on that not
the division so we're going through this
polarity
flash point at the moment and there's
this like it's like potential planetary
dystopia
right on the horizon it's kicking in and
it's like just at that moment there's
potential hope i mean all the
traditional narratives have it it's the
dance of the the yin and the yang you
know the
the dark and the light but it's like
it's like
it's time for the light i mean i think
we can start focusing on that if we
focus our intention in these times of
change
it can magnify because we need to hold
the intention that's why we need
mythologies and maps and pathways and
possibilities
because everyone's going down that way
and there has to be that law of polarity
counter balance okay where's
where's the action plan what are we
going to do how are we going to mobilize
how we're going to focus on ourselves
while everything else is collapsing
and still hold space for for what is
revealing in ourselves because maybe the
light's going on more as
the emergency continues
it feels like the top item
on the action plan and as we mentioned
this turn inward
of course and then in terms of
having this macro level view
it's like taking this
archetype that is decentralization
and making it more pronounced in our
social contracts
so as we've
mentioned before if you have this
evolution of fungi and then this billion
year intelligence
and then 650 million years ago there's
this
animal split from that fungal
intelligence
evolutionary trajectory and then over
the span of just the last couple million
years this
transition from the mammalian chimpanzee
to the
human and when you look at that
ancestral lineage you see that the
the fungus is this most incredibly
beautiful
decentralized harmonic
essence of what not only the planet is
but what the cosmos is
and then you take what is
the emergence of the internet and it
looks just like
the fungal networks and you take what
looks like
this emergence of cryptocurrency and
decentralization
and again looking just like the fungal
networks
and so how do you do on an architectural
level
what is like the first action item
around
meeting the sustainable development
goals is viewing
humans like a fungal network because
when you begin
viewing humans like a single fungal
network
you recognize that the why are we
aiming to meet sustainable development
goals is because
that that is literally our fellow
brother
sister across the planet and that in
order for them to have their basic needs
be met
and to have them be locked in at a
social contract level
for shared equity in the planet's
prosperity that then it enables them to
actualize their
greatest gift and it's just like you you
me rak we all came from this
civilizational inheritance
and for us to be able to be having this
conversation
is based on our us as
this fungal network having enough
nourishment at our basic needs level
that enabled us to be able to have
conversations that are more metaphysical
and so for people to have metaphysical
conversations
like in spiral dynamics or in the levels
of consciousness or any of these
greatest
maps around what enables people to
have these greatest epiphanies about the
nature of reality
the oneness the unity it requires for
these
lower chakras these most limbic primal
needs to be met so they don't feel
like survival haste they don't feel
haste around safety
they feel like they're nourished with
basic
air water food shelter education
electricity
and then they're able to pursue this
buffet
of what is in their highest excitement
and what interests them the most
and then to over time shift more and
more into
alignment with unity and oneness and so
treating this entire thing
like a fungal network seems to be at the
pinnacle of what can be done
it's my cellular yeah yeah i mean it's
networks versus hierarchy so the ego
creates
hierarchies and it's just distracting
from
the big thing into the little thing it's
it's a very infantile
um patterning to create a hierarchy
because there's energy inefficiencies
and it's one way right and so networks
all through nature
it's network so it's feeding and being
fed and it's distributing and it's
decentralized
and as you say the the wave of
technological advances we can see
externalized and there's like the
internet and blockchain and
and they're all network-centric and
they're showing the way the power in
decentralization
and so much of the universe and so much
of the way energy you know
works is like it's decentralized it's
like the that's the
the energy efficient modality of the
universe so
what if consciousness was decentralized
and what if you know
we're learning how to come out of the
centralization of ego
into that cooperative unity field of
each other
who are all plugged in and understanding
were all
parts in a greater whole like a species
gestalt and they were plugged into the
planetary
you know matrix which is supporting and
sustaining not just
taking and feeding you know off it but
giving back and remaining in
relationship with it
i mean it's it's relationships it's it's
a
what we're seeing is the breakdown of
the old paradigm entirely imminently in
front of our eyes
on so many levels and you've got to
understand
the base level you know like this
narrative level that all these stories
and the
weaponization of information trying to
say no this is just
you know another another unprecedented
thing or another one it's like the
paradigm is fraying
it's fraying and it's like you've got to
tune into your center
you know it's like what do we always do
in times of upheaval is we we search for
meaning
it's like which way is up like when
we're destabilized we're looking for up
and in this case the center is
everywhere
right and you are the center perfect and
you look within
and the same lessons and the same
stabilization
that can bring you can help you
navigate the chaotic times which are
which are here
yep perfect so you know there needs to
be more mobilization of i don't know you
know like
when there's these movements like when
wim hof becomes popular and everyone
does ice baths and there's life path
challenges and
and all of a sudden there's like a meme
swarm across the planet where they all
do like
funny things but they're maybe health
orientated it's like wow it's like the
meditation hive mind pop
up and you know we start we start just
doing things which
like we do i went to a beautiful tapanga
um
song circle on last wednesday night
which was great and we all participated
and it was learning songs and it was
random and it was a circle and tp
you know the whole shebang um but the
beautiful thing was when we were like
synchronizing as a group and we were
learning new information and we were
being vulnerable and we were sharing and
it was social
which is so important to reconnecting
without all the labels and without the
nine to five game
and sharing information like songs and
growing each other through that process
hearing each other synchronizing you
know when the voice is all synchronized
together
and it forms this little bond of
community so if we do more of the
community stuff which brings us together
and we're in training with modalities
song meditation you could do the ice
bath challenge
you know stuff which is like
experimenting with our physiology and
our consciousness
together then i think that we would be
taking advantage of the wave which is
building
that's really great
visualization for us is to see what it
looks like
when these mimetic
spreads happen because
it's one of the fastest ways to deploy
an update to the fungal network is
through one of these like
memetic fires
and and so i love that
and so now it's up to us to figure out
well what
could be these
core memes that we could make around
the turn inward and the turn towards
unity and oneness
that could be a memetic fire that would
create people ex excitement around
the that turn in word towards unity
oneness consciousness
all right so here's probably a simple
one you know how you've got like the
muse headbands which
help entrain you into like from beta
alpha like going into meditative states
and you wear the headband and it's got a
little rhythm or pulse or something and
it helps you
hold come back to the moment and learn
one of the the things that everyone
loves about all the internet stuff is
when
like it's a group chat or it's a group
thing it's like everyone's post zoom
burnt out but the idea of
that we're real time engaging with our
peer networks right
and if we're doing something everyone
you know we said like the wim hof
challenge but everyone's doing some idea
that comes around together in their peer
networks
but you could easily have like five
people with like the muse headbands
learning how to entrain together and
comparing their stats i'm sure there's
like a body system thing where
you know so it's like you're learning
how to go within you're not doing it
alone
i think that's the key right to have
containers
where you're even if you've got a
meditation class together but it's like
you know i mean we could bleed into
entheogenics here and have a few
suggestions but
it's like the idea of ceremony and the
idea of container and exploring
consciousness
as a group together i think the social
aspect is important
and there's this huge wave out there now
in psychedelic communities of
integration and meet up communities and
things like that
i'm really waiting for psychedelic
culture to sort of turn the corner and
not wait on a peer-reviewed medical
study to say that
um you know taking ecstasy will help
relieve your anxiety
it's like it's like okay you can do
stuff as groups together
safely maturely you know experimenting
with consciousness go out into the woods
on antigen of choice with an intention
as a
conscious workshop you know and
experiment with the ecodylic bonding
with nature
you know there's there's a i'm sure
there's a sliding scale
system of how much you're bonding with
nature you could apply you could do your
own citizen science while on
an ecodelic you know it's time to
re-engage
versus waiting for the permission of of
daddy to say that it's okay to do
psychedelics everyone's already doing it
but where's the cultural vision the how
they're doing it
it can just become an easy soma for the
masses not just in the
the western um psychedelic renaissance
therapeutic thing which is stuck in the
the capitalist model like
like six eight grand for uh two three
mdma sessions with two therapists it's
like
you know there's that frequency and then
there's like the
the decriminalization movement so
everyone has access to materials which
is great it's getting better
um and it's like okay in this time of
imminent planetary transformation what
is my intention while i'm going within
is there an intention i can hold that
maybe others hold that we can all start
to share answers
and create a knowledge base around what
the connection to spirit ancestors
you know the planet is saying what are
we bringing back from the experience
mckenna's whole
you were fishermen and women you know
and your your job is to go
dive deep into the psychedelic spaces
and bring information back which is a
benefit to the to the culture
and not ideas which is so big they're
unworkable or so small that they know of
use
but just the ones that fit the ones that
are worth bringing back to these times
now
so this is huge and this is something i
would need to give
emphasis to that in times of crisis come
opportunity and the emergence comes from
the emergence and we're living through
unprecedented times right now what is
the psychedelic shamanic right response
to the emergency so when if we're
continuing to have
journeys in altered states which are
either mediated in a container of
therapy for healing
or maybe a shamanic ceremony for healing
or
enlightenment or self-growth
we're working on ourselves and as we
said we work on ourselves because then
we change the word
world on the outside the world on the
outside is feeding back to us right now
shit's hitting the fan like upgrade
right now
it's like you know this is it i mean if
you ever this is it this is it
it's like here's some steps you could do
like what are we getting what are we
bringing back from these
these relationships that we can share
with each other
to make sense of what's happening on the
outside because knowing what's happening
on the outside is a reflection of the
inside and the human psyche
is so in crisis and the binary polarity
points and the
contraction and expansion it's building
to this charge and it's about to go
and what are we going to do about it
what is the correct response
from the shamanic psychedelic community
who understands that there's an ecology
that we're connected to energetically
and we're in relationship with it i mean
we could focus
journeys on not just our own individual
healing but on the species survival
on this thread through the labyrinth
right
this map this idea of well have you ever
considered like oh you know like
ideas come in these states you know you
have the famous examples of um
crick and watson with the dna it was a
crick or was it watson that took the
lsd creek i think it was so francis
creek
yeah yeah yeah i mean you know you have
um what's some other ones i mean
famous ideas what the doormouth saw by
um
is a famous book on silicon valley and
some of the the ideas they got when they
they're in
you know default mode network lowered
states because creativity is freed up
steve jobs steve jobs um yeah there's
been
there's lots of others um but the idea
is we
we need new ideas potentially even
the biblical stories with the burning
bush and the acacia bush on mount sinai
i know i know i know
but the point is the point is the narrow
band with the vigoic western
consciousness which has contributed to
the problem that we're in which is in
itself
part and parcel of the largest cycle of
consciousness being broadcast
um has brought us to this point of
crisis particularly
to initiate the initiation
right so when we're going into these
spaces let's think about that or let's
let it
tell us what it thinks about that and
what is the correct way forward i mean
that would be amazing if we could have
like
you know there's this community called
deep adaptation right
and it's dr jim bendel who wrote the
climate scientist who
released a report about two years ago
saying it's all [ __ ] hitting the fan
the feedback loops where
you know and the denial in the
scientific community which is trying to
you know patent to its corporate
sponsors and the governmental things and
it's there's a there's a narrative um
blanket
again the narrative control on because
they're saying you know people will pay
people panic and
deep adaptation has been flourishing for
about three years
as a community around the world which is
going through the five stages of grief
denial rage acceptance all that stuff
and is aligning spiritually
from the from who they are from going
through this initiatory experience
they're going with the flow of the
initiation they're not contracting from
it
where the mainstream is still catching
up to the fact that it's contracting and
it's
once again old normal but there's this
mythic
initiatory opportunity
right here right now you know that we're
all part of and how we respond to that
and how much we let in
how big this this thing really is yeah
that's a perfect way to tell the story
so
mythic opportunity
for you to investigate the nature of
your reality
and how you can dissolve more and more
of the ego
and separation and the scripts that
promulgate that
and awaken more of your higher
possibilities
for unity for oneness for consciousness
for awareness
for infinity for planetary prosperity
for meeting basic needs for actualizing
gifts
so it's a big metaphysical pressure
cooker
right now and to
sense that and the unique
mythological beautiful
opportunity is it
that's it yeehaw
the other flat there alan yeah yeah
alice is like
hey this is it yeah look it's it's i
mean we don't have to say just look out
the window look at the the news feeds
it's like
you know these are times of great change
and so
um look within to find that change i
just think one of the
one of the little keys that i find is
you know tim leary's old old quote find
the others and you know
the modern spiritual sort of responses
there are no others right
perennial wisdom yeah it's like but it's
like in the search
of finding the others we find ourselves
and that we
mean the ones that are connected to that
well i mean
those of your tribe or of your your pod
right your close pod who are holding
space for you as you're holding space
for them
in this collective journey of
transformation so it's not something
we're meant to do alone yes the journey
look within
you can do that alone but what i'm
saying is it's a collective experience
the world grief and the acceptance of
what's happening
and then of the potential for imminent
transcendence right
but this journey to be taught the skills
to be supported in holding and in
training
that high vibration where it's not a
negative thing it's not a sad thing
it's raising your vibration as you said
beyond the old attachments to form
beyond the old the old karmic samsaras
the illusions that we carry the
the you know the addictions to this old
civilization
it's like the reality grid is just
fraying and it's freeing up
and i really feel that we
we walk each other home as was it ellen
watson
yeah it said always give them computers
yeah could do a youtube mashup of the
book
yeah and but the thing is it gets easier
with strength in numbers it's almost
like you know this little term the
samadhi mesh network
so the more people that can hold the
vibration and can hold it
the field radiates more and it can pick
up more of the signal and then more
people in that field
it becomes like a satellite dish of
consciousness so as
if you can get into that state of
self-awareness and self-knowledge
and and let it you know shake loose all
the lower vibrational energies and
you're purifying the vessel and just
being a bridge
and then if you're coming together in
pods right
to entrain and support and teach
how to access that vibration
then it sort of comes cohesive and it
goes into a phase state where it can
lock in and then
the more it locks in then the samadhi
mesh network can spread perfect
these are just ideas my friend these are
ideas that's all i do
all i do is ideas but also direct
experiential
knowledge as well because you can tell
through a feedback mechanism that
happens is
as you gain more of your sovereignty
as soon as you unfreeze some of that
scripted
behavior that was around accessing just
an application on the smartphone
subconsciously and as soon as you start
unfreezing it you immediately get a
feedback mechanism
which feels more open it feels more
conscious it feels more aware
and so you get the feedback mechanism
that indicates what
rack's sharing with the samadhi mesh
network although it's sort of this
initial stages of this more meditative
consciousness this more unity oneness
consciousness
you're getting it right away as a
feedback mechanism
every time you unfreeze more and more of
your will towards this unity oneness
consciousness
it's critical the the other little
tidbits worth dropping is that you know
it's like a a stone has been dropped in
a pond
and that the shock waves of that are
what we're feeling but there's there's a
greater intelligence running the show
right whether you call that nature with
global warming or humans contributing to
it or
i mean energy and and potential life
doesn't stop at the
terrestrial you know biosphere of earth
it's like there's
there's stars which there's there's
whole planetary system like the scale of
the game keeps going um
play the game well play the game well my
friends
play the game well perfect uh-huh
logos one thank you for coming on
simulation episode five my bro
thank you atlas huh yeah doing good work
yeah
yeah find the others you too yes there
are no others we got this
i love that it's a classic platonic
dialect find others
there are no others yeah it's perfect
uh-huh
oh all right thanks everyone for tuning
in
infinite love for you we would love for
you to
let us know how you feel about the
episode in the comments below
let us know and also if the video
brought you value give it a like
helps that algorithm subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet
and also share the video with other
people that you feel like
it would resonate with all the different
things that rock was talking about
if you really feel like this could land
in someone's heart well
and catalyze great change give it a
share with them
and that is all you can check out rack's
links in the bios below as well go and
give him a follow check out his other
content he's got great content across
those links
and that is all again
infinite love play the game well
[Music]